ladakh a cold Himalayan desert in
northern India here but this monastery
is in the district of Li have been
standing tall for centuries winters are
harsh for six months a year this remote
region is mostly cut off people in lay
depend mostly on tourism local
politicians say the regional government
of Jammu and Kashmir has long neglected
them we were under represented in the by
Indian Parliament and also in the State
Assembly and it was a completely well
eccentric administration there are
thousands of employees in the state
secretariat in Srinagar and Jammu
there's hardly any Ladakh idea the
people of leh have long demanded a union
territory for Ladakh the decision to put
the region under the direct rule of New
Delhi has had a mixed response from the
communities determined to preserve the
unique ethnic and religious identity as
well as their land in August Prime
Minister Narendra Modi said he wants to
open the region to investments and
development nearly all the people of
flake offering tribal communities and
many are concerned about the changes
outside investment might bring to the
local economy and culture tourism is our
backbone second is agriculture we will
not say no to outside investments but we
have so many hoteliers and travel agents
of own and many hotels are running empty
so when our own people are suffering
how will outsiders benefit more than 200
kilometers away
many Muslims and cardio district are
also anxious they include farmers like
Mohamed Abbas jinke we are scared
because Jammu and Kashmir was earlier
under protection and now that protection
is gone you're scared that Outsiders can
come and buy our land outsiders who have
a lot of money most of the people living
in Kargil ischium
they opposed splitting of
indian-administered Kashmir and say they
want safeguards when a thug becomes a
union territory or UT today were in a
no-man's land
we didn't demand aut status no one asked
us it was imposed on us earlier we had
land protection job security and we
could make our own laws the government
is also working on several investment
and infrastructure projects in the
region how all these changes will affect
people's lives here they can only wait
and find out
Priyanka Gupta al Jazeera Lai